snapchat sort of in a position where
they have to become a platform to
compete because Facebook and Instagram
have sort of just declared like did you
see today snapchat did a like I do
they're like Developer Conference thing
yeah tell me about that thing that they
introduced so they introduced us a few
things and they were like hey you know
last time we introduced games and games
are doing great and they were talking
about just kind of hyping up games to
get more people to build mini games on
snapchat but they introduced other
things called minis and minis is
actually I think a bigger move by them
so minis are basically the mini
applications built into snapchat what
they're doing is they're copying WeChat
which is the big messaging app in China
we chat has like a million little apps
built in like oh you need to pay your
bills you just do it through WeChat and
how do you do that well there's this
little mini website but the you know the
utility company makes that'll just pop
up in your WeChat and you hit pay and
it's paid or you want to do this you
want to buy movie tickets together you
do it within WeChat like we don't do
that in iMessage we don't do that in
facebook Messenger but that's what all
these companies would love to bid love
to be WeChat here in the States
so snapchats taking a big stab at doing
that and they announced like so for
example one of the minis is headspace so
you can do like sort of a quick
meditation with anybody else on like one
of your friends from snapchat they did a
movie ticket buying thing they did you
know so they did several of these and
just not again I don't know how the Sox
drive but what's interesting here is
that snapchat sort of in a position
where they have to become a platform to
compete because Facebook and Instagram
have sort of just declared like we will
steal your we took your mojo already and
if you come up with some new great mojo
like guess what you know Evan Spiegel
you're the head of product at Facebook
actually whatever you come up with we
are gonna put in our apps as soon as
humanly possible so their only strategy
they have basically two core strategies
one is maybe they can create snap
classes these like AR glasses and they
can just sort of get off the cell phone
game and get into the glasses game
before anybody else so that would be
like a snap mini website they call them
snap minis and what they are are little
mini websites that that can pop up and
be a little like utility things to do
inside snapchat besides message each
other
now the second thing is becoming a
platform because Facebook and Instagram
don't do a great job of letting other
companies build [__] on top of them
people distrust those companies they've
built apps on top of Facebook and
messenger before and gotten screwed and
so they don't have great ecosystems so
snapchats kind of pushing their chips
into the middle of the table and saying
come build [__] on us we'll treat you
better than those guys will and you kind
of leave it you kind of believe it
because it's really their only way to
compete with Facebook and Instagram so
they kind of have to actually honor this
so anyways a quick idea so in general I
think that being early to these
platforms in these app app ecosystems is
a good thing there's been several snap
kit apps that have been like number one
and number two on the App Store's so
they've gotten a [__] ton of
distribution from it what's a snap snap
kit is basically the tool set that
snapchat gives you to build build stuff
so it's like okay snap kit will say you
want to access their bitmoji cool snap
kit lets you just type one line and you
get their bitmoji character you can do
stuff with snap kittens their camera
with all their lenses I'm doing this
course with Goggin and things we talk
about our inflections so what are what
our inflections and there's a variety of
styles of inflections there's technology
inflections which is like basically like
oh my god the Internet is now in
everyone's house that is an inflection
there's an opportunity there or a belief
inflection is like wow people really
don't trust the media what can we do to
help or people are afraid to be in
groups of thousands of people how can we
fix it
what we are seeing right now is a
technology inflection or a platform
inflection is the detection yes and this
is it this is like when so Pandora the
music company Tim told me that the
company was around for three years and
it was doing horrible and he said they
heard about the Apple Store for some
reason Steve Jobs reached out to them
and said you guys might be a good like
place to put your [__] here and once
that happened he was cool and this I
don't know if it will be but this is
potentially one of those yeah these are
asymmetric bets
[Music]
you